Ahh.
Two more, coming right up.
Bucky's got all the luck.
Yeah, she's pretty.
No, not that.
Lucky b*stard is shipping out tomorrow.
He's going to be a stone's throw away
from the Kr*uts
while the rest of us will still be flying practice
missions over Nebraska.
Don't worry, we'll be over there
dropping bombs soon enough.
Bucky, next round's on us.
He's never done that before.
So you're Bucky, and he's Buck?
Eh, it's a long story.
They make a nice pair, don't they?
Ah, I should have introduced them earlier.
He's leaving tomorrow.
Everyone needs someone
to write to back home.
I don't know if John Egan's the pen pal type.
Well, maybe if he met a girl worth writing to,
he would be.
A girl worth writing to is hard to find.
Not if you know where to look.
I see what you mean.
So you'll write me?
Well, I already have.
You wrote me a letter?
Yeah.
What's it say?
Well, you'll have to wait and find out.
Well, when will that be?
Oh, when I ship out.
I'd say two or three weeks.
I'm going to miss you every second.
All right, all right.
Gentlemen, a toast.
Buck, Marge, hey, you lovebirds,
we're toasting Bucky over here.
Hear, hear, Major Egan.
To our new air exec, Bucky.
All right, Major.
Of all the drunks in the 100th.
Well, someone's got to make a nest
for the rest of you dodos.
Cheers, Major.
To the 100th.
Best of luck, sir.
Good luck, sir.
Thanks.
Save some Kr*uts for us.
We're going to Slooter's.
You guys coming?
Nah.
I got to fly early.
Buck?
I don't think so, boys.
See you tomorrow then.
Bye, Marge.
Bucky, see you in England.
And remember, I want extra blankets
and a cot with a view.
Consider it done.
He won't tell me.
What's with the nicknames?
Spill, Marge.
Go ahead.
Told you, it's a long story.
Well, they met in basic training
before the war started.
John, uh– John was always Bucky
since he was a kid, right?
That's right, yeah.
And Gale well,
Gale's always been Gale, until–
First day of basic training,
this fella walks up to me
and says that I remind him of a guy back
home in, uh, Wisconsin.
Goes by the name of Buck.
I tell him my name's Gale, Gale Cleven.
And Bucky here, he's not deterred.
No, sir, it's just Buck this, Buck that.
Buck, can you help me tie my shoes?
Buck, help me fly this plane.
Before I know it, the whole damn
Eighth Air Force
is calling me Buck.
What kind of a name is Gale anyway?
Oh.
You know what-- you know what,
you should actually
be thanking me.
I did you a favor.
For giving me the same name as you?
It's not exactly the same name.
And it's not my fault you look exactly
like Buck from Manitowoc–
From Manitowoc.
–Wisconsin.
What kind of man does that to
his best friend?
Oh, it's so sweet.
We need music.
OK, don't go away.
Gale– Buck–
you're going to dance with me
before this night is through.
Oh, don't make me dance, Marge.
Pick a good one,
Artie Shaw, Benny Goodman.
Hey, you know,
I am amazed that we're friends.
You don't like to dance
with a beautiful woman.
You don't drink.
You don't gamble.
You don't even like sports.
Well, we are one of life's great mysteries.
[JUKEBOX PLAYING]
Oh, I love that.
Yes.
Yeah?
[EXHALING] So this is it?
This is it.
See you in a few weeks.
If I don't die first.
Hate to break it to you, Bucky,
but you are
the 100th's air executive now.
You're not going over there
to fly missions.
Look, I, uh–
I had a conversation with the CO
over at the 389th,
and I'm flying with those boys
until you guys show up.
I'll be an observation pilot.
You son of a b*tch.
Yeah, well, someone's gotta
taste a little combat,
tell you what it's really like up there.
Well, don't you die on me
before I get over there.
Don't count on it.
Keep your nose down.
Let's get this fire out.
Come on, faster.
You have to help us.